القصف الايراني واثار ردود فعل ممدده فقد
استنكرت حكومه اقليم كردستان العراق
الهجوم داعيه للمجتمع الدوليه التي خد
موقف واضح تجاه الهجمات الايرانيه قالت
اربيل انما وصفتها بالانتهاكات الايرانيه
المتكرره التي تمس سياده العراق والاقليم
غير مبرره وتشكل انتهاكا صارخا للاعراف
الدوليه وعلاقات حسن الجوار لكن ايران
وصلت التحدي وقالت انها تامل الا تستخدم
الاراضي العراقيه لتهديد امنها حسب ما قال
المتحدث باسمي وزاره الخارجيه ناصر كنعاني
الابعد من ذلك ندد المتحدث بما وصفه بعدم
التزام حكومتي بغداد واربيل بوعودهما
المتكرره المعتبرا ان ايران قامت بما
يتوجب عليها لضمان امن مواطنيها وحدودها
واراضيها دوليه ان دعت بحثت الامم المتحده
في العراق الى وقف الهجمات المتكرره التي
تنتهي سيا البلاد قالت ان مثل الهجوم
الاخير يزيد التوترات بل يتسبب ايضا في
وقوع ماساه السفيره الامريكيه في العراق
الينا رومانوسكي اعتبرت هي الاخرى ان
الهجوم الايرانيه يمثل انتهاكا لسياده
العراق وطالبت بضروره وقف هذه الهجمات
غردت رومانوسكي عن ان الهجمات بالصواريخ
والمسيرات تعرض المدنيين الابرياء للخطر
وتدمر البنيه التحتيه اما القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه فدانت ضربات الايرانيه
عبر الحدود وصفتها بالهجمات العشوائيه غير
القانونيه التي تعرض المدنيين للخطر
وتنتهي السياده العراقيه وتقود ان المنطقه
[موسيقى]
وبالعوده الى الطرف الاخر شريك ايران في
القصف على شمال العراق وهو تركيا فلا يبدو
ان هناك مؤشرات للتراجع في موقفها تركيا
كانت دافعت عن عملياتها العسكريه
باعتبارها ضروريه لمنع شني الهجمات ضدها
ولتامين حدودها الجنوبيه وشددت على انها
تتوافق مع القانون الدولي اردوغان من
جانبه اشار الى عدم وجود قيود على العمليه
مشيرا الى ان استمرارها وارد وربما لا
تقتصر على الغارات الجويه اذ قد تمتد لعمل
بري يشمل العراق وسوريا غير ان هذا الامر
يبقى رهنا بالحاجه
[موسيقى]